Previously I mentioned that REST
is more a set of guidelines than
a protocol itself.
This is because it takes
the HTTP protocol and
applies a few constraints to clarify
communication and resource management.
In this video, I will go more in depth
as to what these constraints mean for
us as API developers.
The first constraint of a REST full
implementation is the separation of
clients and servers.
A client is defined as
a machine requesting a resource
where the server is the machine that
responds with the requested resource.
A machine can function as a client and
as a server, but for the duration of
an HTTP request and response cycle,
it must assume the role as either
the requester of the information or
the holder of that information.
A stateful architecture remembers
a client's activity between requests.
If you've ever used a website
where you have shopping cart or
login session, it appears as though
the server is remembering your activity
throughout the duration of
your time on the website.
A truly RESTful architecture, however,
is not allowed to retain information
about the state of another machine
during the communication process.
Each request from a client to a server
must be treated as though it was
the first request the server
has ever seen from that client.
A server should not remember its clients
and readjust its state accordingly.
The server may only give back up to date
state about its state to the client and
allow for modifications,
if it is authorized to do so.
In lesson four,
you will see how using tokens is a good
way to have a stateless design that
can create an experience that seems
state remembering to the user.
Response messages from the server to
the client are explicitly labeled as
cacheable or non-cacheable.
This way, responses can me cached by the
client if the information on the server
hasn’t changed since the last request.
RESTful architectures must have
a uniform interface between
all clients and servers.
For example, a server must not require
a different way of accessing data
if a client has a Windows laptop
verses an iPhone or a Unix server.
Gaining access to these
end points is the same for
any machine trying to
access this information.
A layered system means that
a client can have access to
endpoint that relies on other
endpoints without having to understand
all of the underlying implementations.
If client A wants to
communicate with server B and
that server goes out to Google or
some other database in order to generate
a response, client A should not have to
accommodate for any other technologies
besides accessing server B's endpoint.
Layering allows very complicated tasks
to be completed without having to
understand all of the underlying
complexities that are required to
generate the response.
Code on Demand is an optional constraint
for RESTful applications, but
it opens a possibility for
code like JavaScript, for example,
from the server to be sent off
to the client for execution.
For more about the RESTful constraints,
feel free to follow some of the links
I've provided in the instructor notes.